let's talk at what's at stake here from
The Daily Mail Putin threatens the West
with total nuclear destruction leaving
no chance of survival in the event of a
strike on Russia as he warns his Satan 2
and flying Chernobyl missiles are ready
for use in ranting anti- us speech was
it worth it is is is is is is Ukraine
really worth this we don't want Russia
to have access to the Black Sea we want
to cut them off and take control of the
of the oil and gas so we are risking war
with a nuclear power and all these
people they come out they say it's a
good thing because Russia's been
weakened I don't I that's not a good
thing if Russia is weakened to the point
where they're scared they have nukes do
you want to back like okay you see a
rabbit right not scary at all huh you
back a rabbit into a corner the amount
of fear you have for that circumstance
goes up just a little bit rabbit's still
not the scariest thing in the world but
now that it's backed into a corner it
might actually try and attack you or
bite you and scratch you and then who
knows you get rabies or something from I
don't know rabbit's going to have rabies
but you don't want to do that right
maybe you don't care because you got to
catch the rabbit Vladimir Putin is a
dude with a bunch of nuclear weapons and
they're like let's back a guy with nukes
into a corner to the point where he says
my only option is total Annihilation MH
and this is the game you get when you
get members of Congress who outright
just say we will cut deals to fund War
so long as you give me my minor
victories and make sure I don't get
fired for my
job yeah this is um a very um crazy
situation that a lot of people have been
warning about as of course the majority
of people don't want war the only people
who vote for the war are the members of
Congress that in my opinion should be
going there and then fighting it if you
really want this war go out there and
fight it the argument that Russia has
been weakened is also being challenged
by a lot of individuals who are bringing
up the success of bricks and the larger
relationship that Russia now has with
India with China with Saudi Arabia and
it's other energy distribution that now
they're moving around the world selling
it to other countries who are now
selling it back to Europe at a premium
so if you look at exactly what's
happening here this isn't just a
Devastation because of of the
possibility of a nuclear war this is
already Devastation for the people of
Ukraine that have started to draft women
into the military this is already a
Devastation for the world's poorest
people since there's a food supply
shortage this is already a horrible
situation for all the people in Europe
who are poor because now their energy
prices are going to be skyrocketing
especially es if Europe has a dark
winter which they're expected to have
which of course will obliterate and
Destroy its family's ability to live and
survive as Germany is now going back on
coal of all things which is just just
ridiculous this conflict needs to be
stopped there needs to be a taunt there
needs to be negotiations no side is
going to get everything that they want
but at least we could stop the madness
of human beings dying for politicians
and oligarchs and corrupted individuals
that take everything for themselves and
and don't give it back to anyone else
there's so many reports of Frontline
Ukrainian soldiers not having the proper
gear we're giving $2 200 plus million a
day to Ukraine $200 plus million dollar
every single day of your money is going
over there where's it going to well
according to CBS News only about 30% of
that goes to the actual people they
retracted that but according to some
estimates that looks like that's the
actual number which just so much
corruption happening in that country as
zilinsky just fired a lot of the key
members of his defense Ministry which
you never do during the middle of a war
why did he do it well we don't know the
the the official explanation has not
been given to us but I think it's pretty
clear it has to deal with corruption at
the highest levels of oligarchs coming
in there enriching themselves when
sending some of their youngest poorest
people to go fight for their Ambitions
which is stupid well we know they want
an endless war but what's so ominous and
dangerous about this is that when they
wanted an an endless war in Iraq they
used weapons of mass destruction as the
pretext for it when we knew that that
wasn't legitimate now it's interesting
because they want they want an endless
war against an adversary that actually
does have weapons of mass destruction
verifiably and we think that we run no
risk of pushing them to the edge it
makes no sense like we were fighting
goat farmers in Afghanistan and Iraq now
we're fighting Putin who's literally
coming on here I didn't sign up for this
war did any of you want this war did
Congress vote on this war and what's
obnoxious is that Democrats came out
after the speaker turn turnover and now
they're saying we will not back anybody
that does not prioritize Ukraine funding
as one of the highest priorities not
once did they mention a peace deal like
zalinsky comes to Congress we could have
said dude you do not step foot on
American soil until your number one
priority is a peace deal no more
aggression well they had peace deals but
then the US came in and sabotaged those
peace deals as of course this is a
banker war and it's a it's not only a
Forever War it's a limited Forever War
it's a Henry Kissinger Doctrine that's
being practiced right now and we're
reaching a point where the ukrainians
are running out of human beings that's
how sad that's how tragic that's how
many lives were lost in this entire
debacle which shouldn't have happened in
the first place yes you could put some
blame on Russia yes put some blame on
Ukraine and NATO I don't care just stop
stop with this stupid War stop with the
Bloodshed stop with the life loss you're
fighting over destroyed territories
you're fighting over politicians saying
I want to tax these people that's
essentially what this war is about which
is insane crazy is the person that was
labeled the Russian puppet president
Trump he was the only president that
Vladimir Putin didn't invade another
country under you know under Bush it was
Georgia under Obama it was Crimea and
under Biden it's Ukraine now president
Trump so Crimea is Ukraine so Ukraine
twice Ukraine twice right but president
Trump he sanctioned the nordstream 2
pipeline the first thing one of the
first things that Biden did
was restart the nordstream 2 pipeline in
Russia empowered Russia and then blew it
up and caused one of the biggest
national disasters in world history but
also I I want to counter back a little
bit on Donald Trump because his foreign
policy with Ukraine also wasn't that
good as he had a lot of State Department
old heads coming in and he allowed them
to pretty much do whatever they wanted
to do Trump uh actually went further
than Barack Obama was even willing to by
sending lethal weapons to Ukraine he set
that very dangerous president which led
us to this current situation he now
currently is speaking up he did say he
would be the the president that stops
the war immediately which is why I think
he's getting a lot of support but also
at the same time he is saying the United
States shouldn't be paying for this war
European countries need to be paying for
this war so there's a little bit of a
conflicting message that I wish he would
clear up and become more president on uh
and and explain exactly how he would do
all of this because um there's an easy
way to do this but I I I want Trump to
at least explain it and make his stance
more uh solidified because he's kind of
wavering a little bit in my opinion well
I think president Trump's track record
when he was in office and the fact that
there wasn't a war uh speaks a ton of
volume the fact no new Wars the fact
that Putin didn't move on Ukraine we
were very close towards a war with Iran
and he did B Syria according to his own
son because Ivanka Trump cried to him
about the Syrian gas attacks which were
false flag
attacks which
son um I'll I'll get to the exact
sources listen listen listen baby
Trump's not perfect but I I mean a
strategy for withdrawal from from Syria
withdrawal from Afghanistan which were
botched botched by the way the the state
department lying to the American people
and Donald Trump but the Abraham Accords
were good his his his efforts towards
peace in North Korea was amazing he
worked on a lot of peace with no new
Wars Serb the North Korea stuff was
great but then he brought in Bolton that
came in and said that North Korea is
following the Libyan model which really
pissed off North Korea and then
destroyed any kind oface talk
negotiations I I don't think we're going
to get this libertarian dream of a
president who's going to come in and
solve everything overnight but it is
undeniable that Donald Trump's foreign
policy was actually good based on the
situation that we are in well and he
listened to intelligence too much he's
got to trust his guy I mean when
intelligence lies to him blatantly about
what's happening on the ground in
Afghanistan in order to Halt a
withdrawal that they then botched a year
later you know I our intelligence
operation in the United States was
behind all this you know he gets briefed
Every Morning by the intelligence
apparatus that sits in a room and says
Mr President if you move the embassy to
Jerusalem there will be nuclear war from
Iran he said nah not going to listen did
it no nuclear war peace and when he
would trust his gut and actually not
listen to John Bolton of the world there
was a natural inclination toward peace
because I think that's uh who the guy is
I mean honestly he truthed what was it a
month ago I just want all the dying to
stop like I just I want dying to stop on
both sides I'll be honest I I think out
of all the candidates I think Vivic has
one of the best kind of foreign policies
out there but second to him I will admit
it is Donald Trump because he's still
one of the few people willing out
willing to to have an anti-war kind of
sentiment which is rare and when you
look at the entire Republican ticket
disantis doesn't want to talk about
Ukraine he doesn't give any answers
about what he would do in Ukraine he
flip-flops on it a lot and it's very
concerning to see so many
neoconservatives kind of aligned with
him as well so I I I would say you know
Donald Trump again not perfect I think
he does deserve to be criticized on some
of his foreign policy but out of what we
have I think he's one of the best well
did you watch The Bill O'Reilly Tucker
Carlson interview uh no I didn't so Bill
O'Reilly disclosed something that I
wasn't aware of or a lot of people
weren't aware of but he was involved in
a conversation with President Trump
talking about designating the drug
cartels as um as a terrorist
organization and he was super close to
doing it and he got like legal Authority
and all these people in he got the
military in and Bill O'Reilly was also
in these conversations according to his
his testimony to the Tucker and you know
so president Trump calls up the
president of Mexico and he says I'm
going to
designate the cartels is a terrorist
organization and we're going to go take
them out and and the President says
please don't do that we're going to have
that's going to cause serious problems
for me and so the president of Mexico
and then Trump they end up striking a
deal where Mexico sends their troops to
the border at both the northern border
to our country and also to the southern
countries to prevent and illegal
migration was down 80% because of this
deal and so he did not end up going
through with designating them as a
terrorist organization he looked at it
as a negoti ation tactic and he got 80%
of illegal migration to stop because of
that that deal and so uh he doesn't want
to disclose what his plan would be with
Putin and zalinsky but he does have
personal relationships with both of them
there was not a conflict when he was
president and so when he says I am the
guy that has the ability to end this war
I believe him I hope so I I I do agree
as well I think I think the day they
announc Trump's the winner before he's
even president the fighting stops thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net